now things are more violent than ever
and honestly i'm really scared to go
back even though they're
risking being shot being killed by the
police
and you know getting arrested i i still
have to be a part of this
myanmar's and tikku protests are getting
more dangerous
a lot of people told me that i should
just stay and miss out when i'm safe and
you know just translate the news to
english and
you know just do whatever i can from a
safe
place but i know that i can do a lot
better and a lot more if i'm on the
ground
tear gas stung grenades and bullets
part of an arsenal being used against
demonstrators
but ak has decided to travel from
thailand
back home to myanmar's largest city
yangon i've always been this guy that
complained how my country is all the
time
and now it's it's changing it's it's
either gonna be
worse than before or it's gonna get a
lot better and
i i need to be a part of this fight he
knows it's a journey
that could end in death or injury
once he crosses the border there may be
no way
back he's been warned escape
could be impossible so i'm at the thai
side of
the border right now and now just
waiting for the bus to take us to
myanmar side
so after a short bus ride probably like
10 minutes uh
we're on the myanmar side now
scary since the military coup in
february
at least 70 people have been killed by
junta forces it's been a few hours
and we're still waiting on myanmar side
immigration
there's a lot of people and it's moving
super slow
so yeah just waiting now and hopefully i
can catch my best
for tonight to yangon this is the only
food that's available
and it's
yeah so the current situation in myanmar
is pretty bad at the moment
on the 3rd of march 38
peaceful protesters were killed um
so many people got arrested so many
people were injured
and honestly i'm really scared to go
back
just done with immigration so i'm gonna
go find a bus and get on it
so i just got on the bus right now and
it's already seven pm so yeah
i'll probably get to yangon around seven
in the morning
so when we left miami they said that the
bus was gonna go all the way
and the curfew didn't matter because
these are official cars from the
government but
apparently not we're stopping because
one of the bridge is closed but for now
we're just waiting here
in this place
good thing i brought my cards now we can
play some games
we've been playing for three hours and
i've won 20 000
chat so it's pretty good we're leaving
now
ark is heading towards yangon a place
which has seen
huge street protests but
also a city where the military has shot
and killed civilians
last night soldiers drove around the
whole town they
um broke the windows of the cars that
were on the street
they shoot at the apartment with the
lights on
we just gotta keep doing cdm and keep
going on protests
keep supporting each other and be
patient and not be violent and
you know we're gonna win